we are indeed with Jennifer you Jennifer
yesterday you came out to the show and
you said I'm going to take it one game
at a time and this is exactly what
you're doing how do you feel right now
and what do you how do you feel about
the round
as a whole
um I think this game went pretty
smoothly uh I probably didn't play the
opening that accurately
um I had like I assume she prepped
something and I'm like kind of didn't
remember my line so much and also just
wanted to get her a little bit out of
prep so I I think I'm probably gonna
play the most accurately but um at some
point I think I started out playing her
and I don't think it was any big
problems so it was pretty good and what
about Sophie's game like what was your
take on that I saw it and then at first
I thought she it was like some I didn't
know she was down my piece her opponent
so I thought um it was like down by Pawn
at first and I was like okay maybe some
just some opening thing I don't know
about I never realized she was down by a
piece I was like okay well that happens
I guess
but you're still maintaining Striking
Distance to Sofia she does have a very
difficult match against Alia tomorrow
how do you feel about your chances are
you thinking about that game between
these two ladies at all or once again
you're just focusing on your own game
um well I don't really like to leave it
up to other people to sign how my
tournament goes so
um I mean I guess it's really out of my
hand so it doesn't matter I'm gonna
obviously trying my best to win tomorrow
but it's not like I'm not gonna count on
um that game changing my tournament and
let's take a look at today's game as
well now just uh simply tell us where do
you feel like you're taking over and
where do you feel like you're building
up a decisive advantage
yeah so after
um E5
93 E5
um yeah around this point it's she's
starting to go backwards and then I have
an initiative to start pushing on the
king side and I think this is just much
better now anyway
um
and she didn't seem to be able to build
anything on the queen side yeah I think
like my work on B3 is actually pretty
strong because it prevents
um platform really doing anything and uh
the Bishops and queen is are defending
my position
that's what we thought as well and uh it
seemed like the conversion went quite
smoothly for you Jennifer
congratulations we'll let you go we'll
let you get some rest and get ready for
a tomorrow match a big one
congratulations
congratulations Jennifer and good luck